avec nous le goût ce soir titulaire de
la chair en fiscalité en finance
publique de l'Université de Sherbrooke
bonsoir Luc bonsoir vous êtes ici parce
que on pose cette question est-ce qu'il
faut augmenter les taxes sur le prix de
l'essence toute cette réflexion la part
des gouvernements comment financer le
réseau routier et vous venez de publier
une étude sur le sujet mais d'avoir
revenons à la base quand on prend le
prix de l'essence comme on vient de le
voir c'est évidemment le prix du produit
pétrolier plus les taxes les taxes en
fait qui existent depuis 1924 sur le
carburant et qui servent à quoi en fait
les taxes existent donc depuis presque
100 ans et dès le départ c'était pour
financer des coups de voirie payable par
le gouvernement du Québec ça n'a pas
trop changé il y a en 2010 il y a le
ministre Bachant qui avait dit on va
aller plus loin on va créer un fond un
fond pour le les fonds pour le
financement des réseaux de transport
terrestre qui comprend les réseaux
routier et les infrastructures de
transport en commun il y a du la taxe
sur le carburant va être dédié à ce fond
là
financer donc toutes les dépenses à
partir de ce fond là on va le voir plus
loin mais il faut être un peu
déficitaire oui c'est ça exactement les
automobilistes en ce moment se plaignent
évidemment
en ce moment mais de tout temps si on
peut le dire de payer toujours plus de
taxes les prix grains mais ce qu'on voit
ici dans ce premier graphique c'est le
fait que les revenus tirer la taxe sur
les carburants baisse quand on compare à
la taille de l'économie qu'est-ce qu'on
voit lui qu'est-ce qu'on voit dans le
fond c'est le prix de la taxe sur le
carburant est en fonction du litre et
non pas fonction du prix et donc les
litres augmentent pas aussi vite que le
prix est ce qui fait qu'au fil des
années on va pas aussi vite que
l'économie et donc la taxe perd de
l'importance on le voit le seul moment
où on n'a pas perdu une petite légère
c'est 2010 à 2000 traces moment où le
ministre Bachant dont on vient de parler
à augmenter d'un scène le litre pendant
4 ans et c'est à ce moment-là que la
taxe est un peu constante augmente on a
revu on revoit la chute maintenant en
importance donc ce qu'on comprend et ça
nous le en fait que quand on voit le
prix de l'essence varié autant passer
d'un dollar 50 un dollars 75 au dessus
de 2 dollars l'an dernier c'est vraiment
le prix des produits pétroliers qui est
à l'origine de ça pas la taxe non c'est
vraiment le coup du brut avant raffinage
qui fluctue beaucoup alors que du côté
de la taxe elle est assez stable la taxe
d'accès fédéral sur le carburant n'a pas
bougé depuis 28 ans la taxe du Québec
elle n'a pas bougé depuis 2013 donc ça
fait maintenant 10 ans qu'elle n'a pas
bougé et c'est pas les taxes qui
augmentent c'est le prix de l'essence et
les fluctuations qui en découlent on va
voir un autre graphique qui suggère que
bon le consommateur peut avoir
l'impression que les prix de l'essence
ça pèsent de plus en plus sur les
finances personnelles les différentes
taxes sont souvent remises en question
mais là ce qu'on voit c'est qu'en bout
de ligne les prix ont peut-être pas tant
que ça augmenter
pour comparer des choses comparables et
donc si on recule il y a 10 ans on paye
le même prix à un sous près le litre le
prix avant tout les taxes et plus bas
aujourd'hui qui ne l'était on a même
rajouté la
tarification du carbone le spepede on
est malgré ça on arrive au même prix qui
a 10 ans donc les gens ont le sentiment
qu'on paye plus cher parce qu'on a tout
le temps de sentiments qu'on paye trop
cher présent mais dans les faits c'est
pas ça s'avère pas donc ajuster à
l'inflation en bout de ligne et les
taxes aussi même chose comme on le
mentionnait reste donc à peu près au
même niveau est-ce que cette situation
là bon on a l'impression que les prix de
l'essence varient beaucoup d’une région
à l'autre ont montré les différentes
régions du Québec c'est le cas aussi
entre les provinces il y a certaines
promesses qui ont réduit au même
suspendu la taxe sur l'essence c'est
peut-être l'Alberta on annoncé qu'on
prolongeait
Terre-Neuve c'est temporaire
heureusement pour pour les finances
publiques de ces provinces c'est
temporaire on voit que c'est populaire
donc au Québec on est le champion des
taxes
mais pas le champion du prix au lit
parce que quand on se compare avec les
autres provinces il y a quatre provinces
où le prix ou lait est plus élevé que
nous en avril dernier lorsqu'on a fait
la comparaison lorsqu'on part en
province on peut se comparer entre pays
aussi et je crois que dans votre étude
c'est un des constats les plus marquants
on se plaint des taxes ou de la
fiscalité qui est lourde de manière
générale au Québec au Canada mais en ce
qui concerne les taxes spécifiques sur
l'essence ce qu'on voit le luxe c'est
qu'on est loin d'être le pays où c'est
le plus lourd ce qu'on voit et malgré
dans certaines juridictions dans le
Royaume-Uni qui a une réduction
temporaire aussi de l'essence mais
malgré ça on voit que les États-Unis ont
vraiment des taxes moines donc quand on
va aux États-Unis on le voit rapidement
ici c'est le Québec le Canada pas très
loin mais vous voyez on est vraiment
très bas et vous voyez qu'après quatre
fois plus lorsqu'on arrive en Italie là
en termes de de
sous par litre d'essence c'est vraiment
plus élevé c'est le cas aussi des pays
européens donc on le voit on utilise
beaucoup plus dans ce contexte là est-ce
que vous diriez et particulièrement
quand on regarde le graphique qui aurait
donc de la place pour que cette taxe
augmente sur le litre du carburant là
vous voulez vraiment que je sois pas
populaire donc la question c'est pas ce
qu'il faut augmenter les taxes sur le
message je pense mais la question c'est
on a créé un outil qui est un fond pour
financer lamélioration du transport
routier et du réseau routier du réseau
de transport en commun il est
déficitaire au cours des prochaines
années ils veulent être encore plus
parce que les revenus vont croître pour
simple les dépenses à 6 on va être à 1.7
milliards de déficit en 202728
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on le finance par
les autres revenus et dépenses en
compresseant les autres missions de
l'État indirectement sans le dire où on
fait un geste non populaire d'augmenter
les taxes sur l'essence c'est un peu en
deux mots que la solution se situe quand
vous dites impopulaire on a posé la
question aujourd'hui à la ministre
Guilbaud ministre des Transports qui a
dit on est un gouvernement qui aime pas
beaucoup les taxes donc on a
l'impression que c'est pas une option
qui est privilégiée mais effectivement
ça pourrait être l'une des solutions
pour résoudre ce problème de financement
du réseau routier c'était très clair
merci beaucoup au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI